in a previous video we've introduced
ourselves to the idea of an orbital that
electrons don't just orbit a nucleus the
way that a planet might orbit a star but
really in order to describe where an
electron is at any given point in time
we're really thinking about
probabilities where it's more likely to
be found and less likely to be found and
an orbital is a description of that
where is it more or less likely to be
found
and this diagram shows us the types of
orbitals which can be found in the
various subshells which are found in the
various shells so you have the s
subshell the p subshell that has three
different orbitals in it you have the d
sub shell that has one two three four
five different orbitals in it and then
you have the f sub shells now each
orbital can fit two electrons so if
you're thinking about the subshell the s
subshell can fit two electrons the p
subshell can fit six electrons the d
subshell can fit 10 electrons and the f
subshell can fit 14 electrons two per
orbital
now the goal of this video is to think
about electron configurations for
particular atoms and to help us with
that we will look at a periodic table of
elements
and so first let's just think about the
electron configuration of the simplest
element if we're talking about a neutral
hydrogen atom a neutral hydrogen atom it
has an atomic number of one which tells
us that has one proton and if it's
neutral that means it has one electron
now where would that one electron be
well it would be in the lowest energy
level or the first shell
and that first shell has only one
subshell in it it only has one type of
orbital it only has an s subshell and so
that one electron in that neutral
hydrogen atom would go over there so we
would say its electron configuration is
1s1 in the first shell which is made up
only of an s subshell it has one
electron
now what happens if we go to helium
well a neutral helium atom is going to
have two electrons so instead of just
having one electron in that first shell
we can fit up to two there so its
electron configuration would be one
s two now what do you think is going to
happen when we go to lithium
well lithium a neutral lithium will have
three electrons in it so the first two
could go to the first energy level the
first shell so the first two go 1s2 and
then the third electron is going to go
into the second shell
and the subshell that's going to fill
first is the s subshell so then it'll go
to the second shell and start filling up
the s subshell so notice two electrons
in the first shell and one electron in
the second shell
now what about beryllium
well that's going to look a lot like
lithium but now it has four electrons so
two of them are going to go into the
first shell 1s2 and then the next two
are going to fill up the s subshell in
the second shell i know it's a bit of a
mouthful 2
s2
notice we have 2 we have 4 total
electrons which would be the case in a
neutral beryllium atom but what about
boron
boron gets interesting
a neutral boron would have five
electrons so the first two are going to
fill the
first shell 1s2 now the second two are
then going to go to the second shell and
fill up the s subshell 2s2
and then we're going to start filling up
the p subshell so let's see we have one
more electron so we go 2
p
you're going to have one electron in one
of these p orbitals
and then what happens when we go to
carbon
well it's going to look a lot like boron
but now we have one more electron to
deal with if we have a neutral carbon
atom is going to have six electrons so
that elec extra electron is once again
going to fall into the p subshell in the
second shell because that can fit six
electrons
so we're going to fill the first shell
with two electrons
then the 2s subshell with two electrons
and then we have two more electrons for
the 2p subshell
now you can imagine as we get to larger
and larger atoms with more and more
electrons this can get quite complex so
one notation folks often use is noble
gas configuration where instead of
saying okay this is carbon they could
say that hey look carbon is going to
have the electron configuration of
helium remember the noble gases are
these group eight elements right over
here so it's going to have the electron
configuration of helium
which tells us this right over here
and then from that we're going to also
have 2s2
2 s2 and then 2p2 you could just take
helium's electron configuration right
over here and put it right over here and
you would get exactly what we wrote
before